éventuel passeport vaccinale qui divise
au sein de l'union européenne plusieurs
états membres ont en effet annoncé le
lancement d'un passeport de vaccination
contre le coc vite 19
mais l'idée ne plaît pas à tout le monde
parmi les pays réticents
la france l'allemagne ou encore la
pologne qui jugent sa mise en oeuvre
encore prématuré en cause le manque de
recul sur l'efficacité du vaccin sur les
nouveaux variants le spectre d'une
ségrégation médical et un risque
potentiel d'atteintes aux libertés
malgré sa ferme opposition à un
passeport vaccinale généralisée
l'allemagne n'exclut pas cette
éventualité dans le secteur privé
si un restaurateur veut faire une offre
uniquement destiné aux personnes
vaccinées
il sera difficile de l'interdire dans le
cadre juridique actuel
si l'idée d'un passeport vaccinale n'est
pour l'heure pas ratifié au sein de
l'union européenne
certains états membres prennent déjà des
dispositions dans ce sens la suède et le
danemark ont par exemple annoncé la mise
en place de certificats électroniques de
vaccination destinée aux voyages à
l'étranger à des événements sportifs ou
culturels voire à des établissements de
restauration dans le cas danois des
position également partagée par l'italie
et l'espagne qui plaide pour un retour à
une vie normale au plus vite
de son côté l'organisation mondiale de
la santé se dit favorable au principe de
certificat de vaccination mais se montre
critique sur la mise en place de
passeports indispensable pour tout
voyage nous ne savons toujours pas si
les personnes vaccinées peuvent
continuer à être affectés peuvent
transmettre la maladie en europe 12
millions de personnes ont reçu une
première dose soit 2 7% de la population
peut-être pas encore suffisant pour
proposer le fameux sésame à l'échelle
continentale